Professor Charles
Bailyn: You'll recall that
where we got to last time is
that there are lots of Hot
Jupiters;
lots of Hot Jupiters.
And the alternative theories
that were presented to explain
the evidence for Hot
Jupiters--the evidence for Hot
Jupiters comes in this form of
these velocity curves,
where you plot the radial
velocity versus time of the
star.
And the star goes back and
forth, and you infer from that
that there must be a planet
going around it,
which is pulling the star back
and forth.
And some alternative
explanations were proposed to
explain these kinds of data.
Those alternative explanations
didn't seem to work very well,
and so you have to kind of take
the Hot Jupiters seriously.
Before I go on,
let me mention that,
by now, Hot Jupiters are not
the only kind of planets that
have been seen this way.
There are also planets in--now
known to have much longer
orbits, up to a few years.
These are harder to see for two
reasons.
First of all,
it takes you a few years to see
them.
And second of all,
when the orbits get longer,
the velocities that they induce
go down, because things in long
orbits go slowly.
But, nevertheless,
now we've been able to see a
bunch of things.
Oddly, in many cases,
they turn out to have highly
elliptical orbits,
in some cases.
Not the Hot Jupiters,
not the ones that are close in.
Those all are more or less
circular.
But some of these longer ones
have highly elliptical orbits.
That's also very weird in terms
of our theories of planetary
formation because one of the
things that our theories were
designed to explain was the fact
that all the major planets in
our own Solar System have orbits
that are close to circular.
It does a very good job of
explaining that and then,
naturally enough,
has trouble explaining the ones
we see that are in highly
elliptical orbits--highly
elliptical--yes,
I didn't--highly elliptical
orbits, in some cases.
And just so you know,
the way you recognize a highly
elliptical orbit is it's not
sinusoidal anymore.
It's got some other shape.
So, these come in:
periodic but non-sinusoidal
velocity curves.
So, all this is very amusing
and you pile up all these very
strange kinds of planets,
or what you think are planets.
But there's still sort of the
nagging question of whether
these radial velocity curves
might be explainable in some
other way.
And it would be awfully nice to
have evidence of some other kind
for the existence of these
planets.
This is, you know,
what happens in science.
You find some kind of fairly
strong evidence for something,
but it would be way stronger if
you found two different kinds of
evidence.
Different--collected in
different ways or reflecting
different aspects of what you're
observing that both point in the
same direction.
And, at a certain point along
the way, about six years ago or
so, a new kind of evidence for
the existence of these planets
was discovered.
And the first such case,
which is now a very famous star
for this reason,
was something called HD209458;
that's the name of the star.
And this was a Hot Jupiter
system.
So, this is the name of the
star;
Hot Jupiter was discovered in
the usual way by Doppler
measurements,
by radial velocity
measurements.
And then, something else was
discovered.
So, let me show what they found
in this system.
All right, so let me explain
what's plotted here.
This is the brightness of this
system, not the radial velocity
this time--the brightness
against time.
And so, here it is on the 9th
of September,
1999.
And somebody is measuring the
brightness of this thing.
And it's set up in units so
that the average brightness is
1.
And you can see,
these measurements have a
little bit of error in them.
They scatter around.
And then, at a certain point
there's a dip in the brightness
of the star for a few hours;
notice this is in days.
This is a tenth of a day,
so 2.4 hours,
something like that.
So, for a few hours the
brightness of this thing dips
down to about 98% of its--of the
brightness it has,
so 2--it loses 2% of its
brightness for a little while
and then it comes back up.
And then, interestingly enough,
seven nights later on the night
of the 16th of September,
it did the same thing.
Now, seven nights is an
important number for this
particular system,
because it turns out that the
orbital period of its Hot
Jupiter,
which was already known at the
time, is three and a half days.
So, this is exactly two orbits
later.
The exact same dip occurred.
You couldn't see it one orbit
later because three and a half
days later it's daytime,
and one of the features of
astronomy is that you do it at
night.
And so you have to wait two
day--two orbits to see the same
thing again.
So, every orbit--there appears
to be this little dip.
And what is happening is that
this is a system that's almost
exactly edge-on.
And what's happening is that
the planet is passing in front
of the star, and once per orbit
the planet gets in the way of
the star.
The planet's this little thing,
the star's a big thing.
And a small amount of the
star's light is obscured by the
planet.
This is called a transit.
So, let me just write that down.
And then, transits are
discovered--yeah,
okay, we'll come back to the
overheads in a minute because I
want to show you more plots.
And it's the planet getting in
the way of the starlight.
And what this tells you,
also, is how big the planet is,
because you've got a little
disc in front of a big disc.
And the amount of light that's
obscured--this 2%--tells you
what the ratio of the area
projected by the planet,
compared to the area projected
by the entire star,
is.
So, this gives you an
additional piece of information.
You already know the mass of
the thing because you've
measured the radial velocity.
Now, we also know its size.
So, this was very interesting.
And it is, as I was saying just
a second ago,
an entirely different kind of
confirmation of the existence of
this planet.
So, there's no pulsation going
on here, because some--you not
only are getting the changes in
velocity of the planet you're
seeing--of the star,
you're also seeing the light of
the star diminish when the
planet passes in front of it.
And then, so,
they decided this was
interesting, and so they did
this same experiment,
except with this Hubble Space
Telescope instead of with some
ground-based telescope.
This is what you see with
Hubble, and you can see why
Hubble is a better telescope
than the ground-based stuff.
This is exactly the same plot.
This is the average brightness
of the system outside of the
transit, so this is 1.000.
This is .985 so it's dropped
down 1.5% in brightness.
This is in days and in--this is
a tenth of a day here,
each of these big ticks is .05
of a day.
And here is the star going
along perfectly normally.
And you get better measurements
because you're not distorted by
the atmosphere.
And then, all of a sudden,
the thing drops and it
gets--has this very particular
shape to the light curve,
to the curve of brightness with
time.
This shape is perfectly
explained by the hypothesis that
you're passing an opaque disc
across the surface of the star.
As the disc touches the star it
starts to--and gradually more
and more of the disc is over the
star.
You get this steep drop here.
And then, this rounded part
down on the bottom comes about
because when you look at a star,
the center of the star,
the central portion of the star
looks a little bit brighter than
the edges because,
if you think about looking at a
sphere, if you look at the
center, you're looking right at
it.
If you're looking at the side,
you're sort of grazing the edge
and it turns out there is
something called "limb
darkening,"
which comes about because of
this.
So, stars, if you look at the
Sun for example,
the edges of the Sun look a
little fainter than the middle.
And so, what happens is,
as this disc passes across the
face of the star,
it obscures successively
brighter parts of the star until
you get down to here.
Then, it obscures gradually
fainter parts of the star until
it gets to the edge.
Now, the disc is--as it goes up
here, is passing beyond the edge
of the star.
So, this is exactly the shape
of a light curve you would
predict if you passed an opaque
disc in front of a star.
And it really works out
remarkably well.
In fact, there's a line
underneath these points,
you can see it off here and off
here, which is a prediction.
And you can't see the line
because it's under the point so
nicely.
So, this works out incredibly
well.
This is almost for sure an
opaque disc, namely the planet,
passing in front of the star.
So, transits are
discovered--the dip in light due
to planet passing across the
star.
Now, this does not happen in
every Hot Jupiter,
because you have to be lined up
pretty,
pretty perfectly in order for
the planet to pass in front of
the star.
That is to say if--here's you,
here's an observer,
here's the star.
And, if the planet--if the
orbital plane of the planet
looks like this,
then when the planet's in front
of the star, it'll be below it.
So, if you think about it,
imagine a planet that's
orbiting like this.
Here's its star.
And it never passes in front of
the star, because when it's in
front of the star,
it's below the star.
Whereas, if it--if it's exactly
edge-on, then once per orbit,
it will pass in front of the
star.
But, you have to have a very
precise alignment for that to
take place--so,
requires a precisely edge-on
alignment.
But, if you have such an
alignment, you know how these
dips ought to line up with the
radial velocity curve.
So, now what you see is,
you measure the brightness of
the star versus time,
and you see these dips.
Here's a dip.
Then one orbit later,
you get another dip,
and so forth.
If you then,
at the same time,
measure the radial
velocity--and again,
this is the radial velocity of
the star--then you know how this
has to take place.
Because here you are.
You're looking at it.
And the moment where the dip
takes place, the planet's got to
be exactly in front of the star.
That means the planet is at
this point in its orbit,
going that way,
for example,
and the star is in this part of
its orbit, going that way--which
means this--the radial velocity
at the moment the dip occurs has
to be zero.
Because for them to be lined
up, one in front of the other,
they've both got to be going
sideways.
And shortly before that,
the star was moving away from
you, because they're moving into
position, like this.
Shortly afterwards,
the star is coming towards you.
And, remember that positive
radial velocities are coming
toward--or going away from you,
negative velocities are coming
towards you.
So it used to be--it used to be
going away from you,
positive.
It's now at zero at the point
of the dip.
And then it's going to be
coming towards you,
so it has to be that these dips
take place at that point in the
curve.
And so, here again,
it's got to be like this.
And so, the way this has to
work out is something like this.
So, you can predict what the
radial velocity has to be at the
particular moment where the
transit occurs.
And so this works.
This works for HD--what is it?
209458.
So this works out.
So, now you've got a lot of
evidence that this really is a
planet.
Not only is it moving the star
back and forth the way you
expect a planet to do,
it's also passing in front of
that star at exactly the moment
you expect it to pass in front
of the star,
and the shape of the dip that
it creates is exactly what you
would expect if you pass an
opaque disc in front of a star.
So now, you've got a whole
bunch of different kinds of
evidence.
You can ask,
"Does this prove it's a
planet?"
And then you get into this
problem with scientific proof.
What does it mean to prove
something in science?
You could probably figure out
some clever way that it's
actually a pulsating star,
which has a star spot on it
that somehow precisely mimics
exactly the way a planet would
behave.
Impossible that this
would--well not--I should be
careful with that word.
Highly improbably that this
would actually occur in real
life, so I think,
you know--people have the
feeling that science is truth,
somehow, and that,
you know, that you can prove
things in science,
kind of,
to a mathematical certainty.
That actually isn't the case.
The legal standard,
you know, which you're familiar
from cop shows,
of beyond a reasonable doubt,
applies in science as well.
And that's actually a more
appropriate standard to use for
anything, which,
in the law or in the natural
world,
in which you try and reason by
induction.
And so I would say that this,
plus this, plus the shape of
the--of the spectral lines,
which we talked about last
time, plus the shape of these
dips--that's proof way beyond a
reasonable doubt that there's a
planet around this particular
star.
And that really ended the
conversation.
Yes?
Student: Is it always
directly edge-on or could there
be a case in which it's
[inaudible]
Professor Charles
Bailyn: Right.
Student: --sort of like
a little bit below or a little
bit [inaudible]
Professor Charles
Bailyn: So,
is it always edge-on?
Well, orbits don't change,
so for this object it's always
edge-on.
For most objects,
it is not edge-on,
and so, in fact,
what had happened was,
by the time they discovered
this one, there were a couple of
dozen of Hot Jupiters known.
None of the rest of them do
this, because in all the rest of
them, the orbit isn't aligned
properly,
and so the planet never goes in
front of the star.
And so, in the vast majority of
cases, you don't get this.
And so, they only discovered
this after they'd found so many
of them, that one of them turned
out to be aligned properly,
you know, just by chance.
Student: Is there--it
possible for an orbit to
not--never pass in front of the
center of the star?
Professor Charles
Bailyn: No.
What it does is it passes--it's
got to do this,
it's got to have some moment
where the planet is as far
towards you as it can be,
and then it turns around and
comes back.
But for most orbits,
at that point,
the planet will either be below
or above the star from your line
of sight.
So, imagine this orbit as the
planet goes--here's a star.
Planet's going around the star.
It reaches its furthest forward
point, but it's well below the
star from your line of sight.
So, it depends on the angle of
the orbital plane.
Does that make sense?
Student:
It, it doesn't have to pass
through the center of the star,
it could pass [inaudible]
Professor Charles
Bailyn: Oh,
oh -- Student:
[inaudible.]
Professor Charles
Bailyn: Yes,
sorry, exactly right.
It doesn't have to pass through
the center of the star.
It can graze the tip at the
bottom of the star a little bit.
And in fact,
in this object,
you can tell how close to the
center it goes by the exact
shape of the curvature down at
the bottom of that light curve.
Because, you know what the
expected distribution of
brightness across the face of
the star is.
You also know something about
the radius of the star.
This is supposed to be a
solar-type star,
presumably has a radius of the
Sun.
If it passes across,
sort of grazes the bottom,
then the dip will be shorter,
because it will pass through
faster.
And so, you can figure out
exactly what the trajectory
across the thing is.
Most of the time it misses.
And in this case,
you can figure out that the
angle of the inclination,
so-called,
which is 90 degrees if it's
exactly edge-on,
is 80--I think 88 point
something,
I don't remember the answer.
Because, it doesn't go exactly
across the center,
it goes, sort of,
sort of halfway down.
So yeah, that actually gives
you additional information.
How long the dip is and what
the exact shape of the thing,
tells you which part of the
star it passes across.
Yes good, thanks Bethany.
Other questions about this?
Yeah?
Student: Have we ever
discovered a planet through
transit without having
discovered it previously?
Professor Charles
Bailyn: Right,
have we discovered a planet
through transit without having
discovered the previous radial
velocity curves?
Yes, and we'll get to that.
Because, let me just say this:
as soon as this was discovered,
people got way excited,
because it's quite difficult to
make these kinds of precise
radial velocity measurements.
You have to have very
specialized equipment.
Only a few people in the world
can do it.
There's this bunch of people in
California who can do it.
Switzerland who can do it.
Us – normal astronomers,
don't have that kind of
expertise and equipment,
but measuring a change in
brightness of a star by 2%,
that's easy.
I can do it up on Science Hill
[an area of the Yale campus
where the Astronomy Department
is located]
in our little observatory up
there.
In fact, I have done it for
this star.
You can--if the timing were
better, this star is up in the
summertime, unfortunately.
If it were up in the fall we
would have this be an exercise
in Astro 155 [a Yale Astronomy
class],
because it's entirely
straightforward to go and
measure a 2% difference in
brightness in a star.
Anybody, you know,
with 2,000 bucks' worth of
equipment, you can go out into
your backyard and do this
experiment.
This is a big deal.
So, as soon as that was
possible, everybody got fired
up, you know,
"I'm going to play this game
myself."
And we all laid very elaborate
plans for going out and finding
zillions of planets.
And the problem is that it has
to be exactly aligned edge-on
for this to even occur.
And so, most stars with
planets--this doesn't happen.
And so, you would have to
observe many,
many, many stars in order to
see this one time.
So you have to--while it's easy
to do for any one particular
object, it's hard to discover
them this way because you have
to do it in bulk.
You have to look at many stars
at once.
So then, people thought,
well, great,
we know how to do this.
We'll look at many stars at
once.
We'll take pictures of star
clusters, of--where there are
lots and lots of stars.
And we'll just keep taking
pictures of these star clusters
over and over again.
You'll look at 30,000 stars at
a time, and if one of them has a
dip, we'll find that dip.
And so, the way we'll deal with
the fact that this doesn't
always occur is by looking at
star clusters.
And so, they tried this,
again, with the space
telescope, because it works
better at doing this kind of
thing.
The problem with star clusters
is that the stars are really
close to each other,
so from the ground it just
looks like a mush.
In this case,
you have to see the stars
separately.
So, they took a particular star
cluster--also the advantage of
doing it from space is no
daytime, and so,
you can observe continuously.
So, they took eight consecutive
days of Hubble Space Telescope
time and did nothing but look at
a star cluster,
a cluster called--famous
cluster called 47 Tuc,
37 stars.
They took repeated images of
this star cluster,
and they figured,
we ought to see some number of
planets by the transit method,
first, in this cluster.
So just, here's what the
cluster looks like.
So this, on the left,
is a ground-based picture of
this cluster,
and you can see what the
problem with observing this
stuff from the ground is.
If you look down in the middle,
it's all mushed together.
You wouldn't be able to pick
out individual stars.
But then, this box here,
blown up to the right-hand side
of the picture--this is what
that little box looks like from
the Hubble Space Telescope.
And now, you have the
resolution to observe each of
these stars, or many of them
individually.
And so they took eight nights
of Hubble Space Telescope
time--that's a lot of time on
the space telescope.
The space telescope costs about
a $1,000,000 a day to run.
And so, this is 8,000,000
bucks' worth of observing time.
Okay, so what did they expect
to see?
So, finding planets directly
from transits.
And so, they observe a cluster
of stars--30,000 stars at a
time.
So, what do you expect?
Well, it turns out,
from the radial velocity
studies, they had gone and
looked at a lot of,
sort of, Sun-like stars.
So, 30,000 more or less
Sun-like stars,
I should specify,
from the radial velocity
measurements from the Doppler
measurements.
They got answers like
approximately 1 out of 10
stars--this is a rough estimate
– have Hot Jupiters.
And then, how precisely aligned
do they have to be?
Approximately 1 out of 100 Hot
Jupiters is aligned properly to
get a transit.
And so, now,
you have a prediction.
You look at 30,000 stars.
A tenth of them have planets,
that's 3,000 planets.
One hundredth of those will be
aligned up in such a way that
you can see a transit.
That's thirty transits.
Predict-- thirty transits.
And it was that kind of
calculation--this is just a
rough estimate,
but they had done this much
more precisely.
It was that kind of estimate
that persuaded the people at the
Space Telescope Institute to
allocate all these many hours of
space telescope time to this
project.
The result was zero transits,
none.
Not seen.
And this was a little
distressing, except it didn't
take people very long to figure
out that they should have known
this in advance.
And this is--you know,
you get a result and then of
course people--you get an
unexpected result,
and then people start writing
papers which say,
well, of course that's what you
should have gotten.
Any fool could have predicted
that you would not see any
transits in a star cluster,
except none of the fools did.
Let's see, so--but,
in retrospect,
it was clear that this wasn't
going to give you the thing you
thought because of two factors.
First, in--why?
So, first factor:
in clusters,
the stars are really close
together.
Stars--they sometimes collide
or more often have near
collisions.
And when a star comes cruising
into your planetary system,
the star has a lot of gravity.
It's going to completely wreck
the orbits of the planets
because you're going to have the
gravity of a second star.
And it turns out that what this
does is it liberates the
planets.
And so, it will disrupt
planetary orbits.
So, you kind of don't expect
there to be any planet;
you expect there to be planets
in the cluster,
but they'll be free floating
planets sort of wandering around
the cluster,
because they will have been
detached from their parent star
by incoming stars--by close
encounters with other stars in
the cluster.
Put it this way.
The nearest star to the Sun,
beside the Sun,
Alpha Cen, is about a parsec
away.
In a cubic parsec,
at the center of one of these
clusters, there are a million
stars.
And so, there are a million
stars packed into the space
where only one star exists in
our corner of the galaxy.
So, they run around--you know,
if you were in a cluster,
if you were in a planet on a
cluster,
and you were looking up at the
sky, the constellations would
change from year to year,
because the stars are so nearby
that their motions would be
readily apparent.
And once every few hundred
million years,
a star would come cruising into
your Solar System and detach all
of the planets from the star.
And so, you don't expect there
to be any planets.
You also don't expect there to
be any planets for an entirely
different reason,
which is, one of the things
that had been discovered as they
were piling up all these Hot
Jupiters found by the Doppler
Shift method,
is that stars are more likely
to have planets--have
planets--if they have high
amounts of heavy elements--heavy
elements.
Now, let me explain that.
Most stars--stars are mostly
hydrogen and helium.
Astronomers do chemistry in a
very peculiar way.
We have--we consider there are
three kinds of things in the
universe.
There's hydrogen,
there's helium,
and there's metal.
Chemists--everything else is a
metal.
If don't care if it's oxygen,
carbon, whatever.
The chemists get really
uncomfortable with this.
But, you know,
it's like the supposed
primitive tribes.
I'm not sure these--this
actually exists,
but the linguists say there are
tribes in the world where they
count one, two and many.
Well, this is how astrono--I
don't know if such tribes exist
except for the astronomers,
who really do.
And we count,
one, two, and many.
And we call any chemical
element heavier than helium a
metal.
So, we have this concept called
metallicity, which is defined to
be the fraction of something of
elements heavier than hydrogen
and helium,
which are the first two in the
Periodic Table,
as you probably know.
So, everything else is a metal.
The metallicity of the
Sun--Sun's metallicity--is about
2%.
And the metallicity of the
Solar System is therefore about
2%, because the Sun's got all
the mass.
And, high metallicity stars,
by which I mean,
metallicities greater than the
Sun--greater than solar--are
more likely to have planets.
This makes perfect sense.
This is the first thing in a
little while that's made any
sense--because,
how do you make a planet?
Well, planets aren't made out
of hydrogen and helium.
Planets are made out of the
other stuff.
We're made out of silicon and
iron, and the--Jupiter's got a
lot of ice, and so all these
kinds of heavy elements--you
don't make--you can't make a
planet if all you've got is
hydrogen and helium because
there's nothing solid to have it
form.
And the only way you get to
keep your hydrogen and helium,
the 98% of the stuff that's
hydrogen and helium,
is if you already have a big
core of heavier--either rocks,
or ice, or something else--if
you already have some metallic,
in the astronomical sense, core.
And so this makes perfect sense.
If you don't have any metals,
you can't be forming planets.
And star clusters of the kind
that Hubble observe are known,
and this particular one is,
to consist of low metallicity
stars.
In the case of 47 Tuc,
the one we looked at,
it's--the metallicity of the
thing is, I think,
about a fifth that of the Sun.
So, it's got very substantially
fewer heavy elements.
So, no planets.
So, in two different ways this
was a mistake,
right?
But that was only realized
afterwards.
And, it's unfortunate that it
was a mistake in two different
ways.
Because if it was a mistake in
only one different way you would
have learned something from
this,
because you would have
confirmed the idea that a
star--close stellar encounters
strip planets off of
stars--except maybe it's only
because of the low metallicity.
Or, you would have confirmed
the idea that low metallicity
stars can't have planets;
except in this case,
maybe it's just because of the
stars and the planets have been
stripped away.
So it's kind of unfortunate
that there were two excellent
explanations different from each
other about why you should have
predicted this result before you
obtained it.
However, having done that,
it was clear what the next
experiment had to be:
that you wanted to go out and
try and measure these transits
in some region that's a little
less dense,
and a whole lot more metal rich.
So, next experiment,
which was done last summer,
didn't look at a star cluster.
It looked at the center--a
region close to the center of
the galaxy.
So, this is lots of stars,
but significantly less dense
than what you would get in the
center of a cluster.
Fortunately,
they had put up a bigger camera
into the space telescope since
then, so you could cover more of
the sky, which was useful.
This is the camera;
by the way, you may have read,
over the weekend,
that Hubble's had a little bit
of a problem.
The electronics in this wide
field camera have shorted out.
And so, Hubble's kind of in
trouble for--until they get the
next visit, because its major
camera is now blind.
And this happened,
I should say,
12 hours after the deadline for
submitting proposals.
So, there had been almost 1,000
proposals submitted from around
the world, of which,
maybe only a fifth would ever
get done.
People in our department and
basically every department in
the whole--astronomy department
in the whole world were going
nuts trying to prepare their
detailed proposals for using the
thing.
They submitted them,
and a few hours later it broke.
And so, then there was this
nice little email from the
people at the Space Telescope
Institute saying,
"uhh, you might want to
reconsider, and we've created a
new deadline three weeks from
now so that you can revise and
extend."
There are other instruments
that still work but the cameras
aren't as good.
And so, now,
everybody's scratching their
head and thinking,
can I actually do this,
and if I can,
what's the good strategy?
Do I want to try and do it now
when the competition's going to
be much less because the
instruments are lousy?
Or, do I want to wait until
after September 2008,
when they're scheduled to go up
replace the camera and repair
the thing,
and try and do it with the good
instruments then,
when everybody else in the
world is going to want to do
their experiment?
And so, we're all grappling
with this at the moment.
However, last summer this was
working like crazy.
And they did another one of
these ten consecutive days of
observations,
but this time of the center of
the galaxy,
which has lots of stars--but
less dense than in the center of
the cluster, and also has the
advantage that many of these
stars,
most of them,
are high metallicity stars.
So, hopefully,
this will work,
right?
Because you've eliminated both
of the excellent reasons why it
didn't work the last time.
So, here is the field of view
that they were looking at.
This is a tiny piece of the
center of the galaxy.
Lots and lots and lots of
stars, which is good,
because you want to see them.
And these little circles here,
which are numbered from 1 to
16, I believe,
are circles around little
Sun-like stars.
You can see the stars in the
middle of those circles;
you probably have a hard time
seeing.
Let's turn the lights down.
This is kind of a nice picture.
This is what the center of the
galaxy looks like to the Hubble
Space Telescope.
And these bright things--the
colors are sort of quasi-real.
These things are red giant
stars and solar type stars.
The center of the galaxy is
quite far away--are really quite
faint, you can barely see it.
See in the middle of this
circle there's a little star
there, that's a Sun-like star in
the middle of the galaxy.
And these circles are these
stars in which they found--in
which they found transits.
So, in this case, it worked.
So, it's true that one or the
other or both of those reasons
they had why it didn't work in
the star cluster,
were in fact the reason it
didn't work in the star
clusters.
Because here's a situation
where those problems don't
exist.
And now they found sixteen of
these things,
which is pretty close to the
amount you would have expected.
And so now it is--these are
planets, which have been
discovered first by the transit
method.
I should say,
there are a couple of others
that have been discovered.
First by the transit method,
from people at the ground just
going out and looking at random
stars.
And in some of those cases,
they have been done the
opposite thing,
and gone back and found the
radial velocity measurements
after having discovered the
tran--the planet by transits.
You can't do radial velocity on
these guys because they're too
faint, and it's just not going
to work out.
Okay, how're we doing?
All right.
Now, a couple of consequences
of this.
If you have both radial
velocity measurements,
which tell you the mass of the
planet,
and transits,
which tell you the radius of
the planet, then you know
something very important.
You know the density.
Density--then,
you get the density.
Density is usually written down
with the Greek letter ρ,
for some reason,
which I don't understand,
but it's always done that way,
so we'll do it too.
And density is defined as mass
of something divided by its
volume.
And so, for a spherical object,
the volume--if you go back to
some geometry book,
you can look this up.
4/3π times the radius cubed,
and that's the density.
The density,
if you--the density of water is
about--is 1 gram per cubic
centimeter.
Now, of course,
that's a lousy set of units.
We do things in kilograms per
cubic meter.
That's, as it turns out,
1,000 kilograms per cubic
meter.
So, if you picture a cubic
meter, that's a pretty huge
aquarium.
It's actually pretty heavy.
And, let's see, is this right?
10^(2), 10^(6) times a
gram--yeah, that's right.
And, in fact,
interestingly enough,
this is the definition of a
gram.
This is where they came up with
that metric unit--is to make it
work out so that the density of
water is one--is exactly 1 gram
per cubic centimeter.
You have to specify the
temperature, too,
because--but,
so, that's a typical density of
water, which is on ice,
right?
Rocks have higher density--much
higher density.
That's why a handful of iron is
heavier than an equivalent sized
handful of snow,
or something like that.
So, if you know the density,
you can tell something about
the composition of the planet.
And it turns out that the Hot
Jupiters, in the few cases we
now have--it's not just one
case, it's several cases--Hot
Jupiters have low density.
They really are ice balls.
They're not made out of rock.
And so, an idea you might have
had about where the Hot Jupiters
come from is,
well, in these high metallicity
stars, there's just a whole
bunch more rock,
and the Earth-like planets kind
of get big.
But that isn't what happened.
These things really are made
out of ice.
And now you have a problem,
because you know how far away
they are from the star.
And the temperature of these
things--the surface temperature
of these things is,
like, 1,000 degrees.
This is not a good place to put
a snowball, all right?
You put a snowball in some
place which is 1,000 degrees--we
won't specify the place--and
something bad is going to happen
to it.
Now, the--and so,
therefore, how could these
planets have formed?
And so the idea--the current
thinking on this is an idea
called migration.
And the idea behind migration
is that you make Jupiters in the
Outer Solar System,
where they belong.
And then, through some
mechanism, which people have
ideas about, but which
aren't--isn't at the moment
really specified--these things,
after they are formed,
they migrate into the Inner
Solar System.
And the reason this is a useful
thing to do is that a big thing
melts slowly.
The reason for that is that the
surface area to volume ratio is
low.
Volume goes up as the cube of
the radius--surface area,
goes up--as the square.
If you shine a light on
something, the amount of energy
it picks up depends on how big
it is, not on how massive it is.
And so, changes of temperature
in interacting with your
environment are less,
the bigger you are.
This is why,
by the way, arctic animals tend
to be big: because they're
trying to survive in an
environment that's much colder
than they are.
And so, they generate energy by
their volume and they lose it
out their skin,
by their surface area.
So, you want to have a lot of
volume compared to your surface
area.
Big things melt slowly.
So, you can't have ice
planetesimals in the Inner Solar
System.
But you can have something the
size of Jupiter.
And it'll melt,
but it'll take longer than the
age of the Solar System,
or even the age of the
universe, to do so.
So this is the idea.
And of course,
the key point here is this
migration.
And there are ideas about why
this should happen,
but it isn't wholly clear.
Now, one thing,
a consequence of this idea,
is that there are no
terrestrial planets.
No terrestrial planets,
because as this Jupiter is
moving inward,
if there's an Earth in the way,
it's going to either knock it
out of its orbit completely,
or the Earth will run into
Jupiter and become incorporated
into that planet.
So, if you've got a
Jupiter-size system in--near
where your Earth-like planet is
orbiting,
that Earth-like planet's in big
trouble for exactly the same
reason the planets are in
trouble,
in general, when another star
comes through,
because you've got something
much more massive coming by,
screwing up your orbit.
So, there are no terrestrial
planets.
Their orbits are disrupted by
the migrating Jupiter.
Now, in fact,
I have to qualify this a
little.
There was a paper that showed
up in the literature,
a few months back,
with some clever way of
preserving the terrestrial
planets as the Jupiter came by.
I have to say,
I don't fully appreciate the
force of this argument.
It is perhaps true--because I
haven't read the paper carefully
enough, but I feel obliged to
mention that somebody,
at least, has an idea about how
you can avoid it.
But, in sort of straightforward
terms, you don't expect there to
be terrestrial planets in a
situation where a Jupiter has
migrated from the Outer Solar
System to the Inner Solar
System.
Questions?
How are we doing?
Yes?
Student: I was just
wondering what caused the Hot
Jupiters to migrate?
Professor Charles
Bailyn: What causes the Hot
Jupiters to migrate?
This is a subject of some
discussion among the experts.
The idea is that when the
Jupiter forms,
remember it forms out of a disc
of gas?
There might still be a
substantial residual gas and
dust disc.
And as the Jupiter plows
through it, the friction with
that disc slows it down.
And if you slow down the orbit
of a planet, it'll gradually
fall inwards.
That's one idea.
There are some--there are other
ideas.
But it isn't clear.
And if it were clear,
you would have predicted it to
happen.
And indeed, there's a whole
problem with the migration
theory.
So, problem with migration is,
sometimes it doesn't work.
Because, Jupiter in our Solar
System is where Jupiter is.
It didn't migrate.
It has to work--needs--so,
the problem with the migration
system is, it needs to work,
but not always.
It also can't work too well,
because if it works too well,
then the Jupiter falls right
into the Sun,
right?
So, it has to work most of the
time, but not all the time,
but not too well.
This is a complicated balancing
act.
And, whatever theory you
propose, whether it's this
friction with a dust disc,
or anything else,
you've got a little problem
with this whole concept.
Because you have to tune this
mechanism up so that it takes
most Jupiters,
moves them into the Inner Solar
System,
and then stops working at just
the right point to leave you
with a whole bunch of Hot
Jupiters,
most but not all of the time.
All right, that's as much as we
know about it.
That's--you know,
you got to come back three
years from now and see if we've
straightened this out,
because that's where we are at
the moment.
All right, more later.